let's go next to our caller from the
seven one nine area code who's calling
today from seven one nine how did Ava
did it me yes it is hey David um so I
was hoping to ask you about a video you
made a couple of days ago where you were
debating which drug should and should
not be legalized yes um and I guess my
main question about that video is that
we don't completely legalize all drugs
even cocaine and heroin and things like
that doesn't that leave the cartels in a
position to still make tens of billions
of dollars every year and subject the
nations of Central and South America to
you know their whims and doesn't that
leave them in power it does I mean so
the best two arguments for legalizing
everything recreationally in my mind are
the you still have a black market and
cartels wielding a lot of power if
something is decriminalized but still
not legalized and you can control the
production such that you know people are
using safe stuff of regulated stuff if
you legalize it so yeah I mean those are
those are the strongest arguments for
legalization it's just it is hard for me
with something that is just as
objectively destructive as heroin or
cocaine it's hard for me to say this
should be a recreational thing in the
way that marijuana or maybe even some
hallucinogenic should be I'm just not
there yet but as I've said before my
position on this is iterating okay
awesome well David thank you so much for
your time and I gotta tell you man
you're like one of my favorite people
like you know in the public spectrum
right thank you thank you David I
appreciate it thank you so much for the
help and on that note let's take a quick
break if you're holding don't hang up
because we will get two more calls right
after this